hey guys how are you so I'm outside now
because I attempted to start shooting
this video in my hotel room but it was
so dark and it's also rumored to be
haunted so I was like I gotta get out of
here like this is just not even
happening it's supposedly haunted what's
happening here you're wondering where I
am right now I'm in Salem quite
interesting there's a lot of witches
my original video I planned on attacking
about technology and how it changes so
quickly to this rant was stemming from
this article that I was reading about
the Sony Xperia z1 it's a camera phone
it's basically waterproof you can take
like blurry photos and you can do so
much stuff and I was just thinking like
my home can't do that and it's so crazy
that years ago the technology that is
inside of a computer or a high-end DSLR
camera is now inside of your phone I
don't even actually ever use my computer
anymore which is the craziest thing the
only time that I really ever used my
computer is to edit videos Izu my email
I do pretty much everything on the go
when I was younger and my first actual
gaming system was a Nintendo regular
freaking Nintendo and after that was the
Super Nintendo and had a Game Boy it
wasn't even a color screen like what
color was the screen black and white do
you know what we had to do back in our
day we had to put a magnifying glass
attached to our Gameboy with a little
light on see who would be able to play
in the dark and actually see the screen
so when I think about that I can finally
get with like my parents my grandparents
were saying it's you know back in our
day we had to walk 10 miles in the snow
to get to school anyway I'm not even
really sure
where this video is going but I'm having
a great time chatting with you guys and
going for a little walk
it also just really is surprising how
many people are staring at me right now
nice place scarcely okay this is
actually very difficult that you're
gonna film outside in which country my
question to you guys is what do you
think in 10 years from now we'll be
telling our friends our family our kids
man you guys are so lucky because you
have this now that we didn't have then
my hope for the future is I really want
some contact lenses that I can put in my
eyes it'll be GPS Wi-Fi I can basically
do everything that I could do on my
phone in my eyes so I've actually been
painful cuz I probably have to get
something implanted into my head also if
you guys aren't aware YouTube has this
thing it's called like an audience tool
but I can see who the top fans are you
want to be a top fan I think you just
leave comments and like and stuff like
that I never sent sure so currently
thank you to these top fans believe one
of them is buck Hollywood so buck I love
you I'm gonna go back into my haunted
hotel now